Freunde endlich wieder einen Tag
persönlicher Koch und heute natürlich
ein ganz besonderen Gast der gerne mal
ins Bild kommen darf Kelvin die Legende
ist heute bei mir zu Gast
Kelvin
[Musik]
Alter meine Freundin ja und jetzt was
soll die von uns denken was soll die von
dir denken oder von mir interessiert
mich das das kommt da jetzt was passiert
da ich habe schon vorher
macht mich verlassen ich durfte mir drei
Gerichte überlegen du hast mir komplett
freie handgelassen die ich für dich
zaubern möchte und zum Frühstück gibt's
direkt was besonderes Steak und Ex du
kennst das vielleicht noch nicht aber du
darfst es dir richtig gemütlich machen
ganz entspannt und ich koche für dich
dann musst du nur essen geil Arbeiten
endlich ist es wieder soweit ich stehe
hier in der Küche werde jetzt für Kelvin
ein zauberhaftes Frühstück zubereiten
und eine Zutat darf bei unserem
Frühstück welches Steak and eggs heißt
nicht fehlen und das ist Jimmy habe ich
um ehrlich zu sein noch nicht so super
oft gegessen in Amerika wurde das aber
immer gereicht wenn man irgendwas mit
Steak bestellt hat deshalb freue ich
mich sehr das ganze zuzubereiten ich
schneide grob den Bund Petersilie unten
ab einfach fein hacken das dauert jetzt
ein bisschen aber es wird sich lohnen
[Musik]
wir nehmen das ganze wir müssen unsere
Schüssel wir geben dazu eine fein
gehackte Schalotte zwei fein gehackte
Knoblauchzehen Chili und den Saft von
einer halben Limette
bisschen Pfeffer und eine Prise Salz so
und jetzt
habt ihr natürlich Recht muss das ganze
noch zu einer Soße werden und dafür
brauchen wir Olivenöl und das geben wir
jetzt in unsere Rührschüssel und das
dann auf dem Steak auf den Eiern crazy
und genau mit den beiden Sachen machen
wir jetzt weiter wir haben zwei
Rumpsteaks 6 Eier Kelvin ist ein
stabiler Typ ihr habt es gesehen das
sieht noch gut aus das sieht sogar noch
ja super gar kein Problem wir machen
Software mit X auf geröstetem Sauerteig
Brot darüber schön medium rare
gebratenes rumstake drüber Chemie ich
glaube wirklich das wird ein richtig
gutes Frühstück ich mache das
allererstes kümmer ich mich mal um die
Eier weil das ist eigentlich alles
vorbereitet hat vielleicht gesehen der
ultimative Trick hat mir einer von euch
verraten zwei Eier aneinander dann gehen
sie perfekt auf ich mag sie immer gerne
Gäste mir so komplett freihand lassen
und dann kann ich irgendwie Sachen
integrieren die wir noch nicht hatten so
auch bei Steaks natürlich ein Uhr
amerikanisches Frühstück in so einem
Steakhaus oder irgendwie so ein Diner
genau das wollen wir heute in fancy
quasi nachmachen und mich zunächst
einmal um das Brot lass ich mal die
Planscheibe heiß werden und schneit mir
in der Mitte bei drei schöne Scheiben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben das Brot jetzt fehlt das Steak
und das kümmern wir uns als nächstes ich
schneide hier einmal ein perfektes Stück
zurecht freue mich darauf ich freue mich
auch selbst einfach zu essen wenn das
ganze hier drüben schön am Rauchen ist
gehen wir ein wenig Öl auf die
planschaft würzen das Steak und beiden
Seiten mit Knoblauchpulver und beiden
Seiten das sage ich dann natürlich von
allen Seiten und dann wenn es schön heiß
ist und drauf können wir auch legen
gucken dass wir schön viel Kontaktfläche
haben hier drüben ein bisschen hoch mit
der Hitze hier machen wir nämlich unser
Ei drin aha guck mal komm schon Alter
zum spionieren
abonniert den Kanal aktiviert die Glocke
schreibt in die Kommentare ja mann
geröstet schon mal gegessen diese dieser
das ist so Petersilie Chili Knoblauch
Olivenöl einfach so richtig schön für
die frische geil Alter kommst du selbst
gerne
ich wohne noch mit Mama weißt du die
kocht immer das Problem
beigebracht das heißt vielleicht noch
ein bisschen was mitnehmen solange du
noch da wohnst ne ja eigentlich sollte
man aber kennst ja ja ja
dann kannst du was essen musst du rufen
oder so
kümmern wir uns jetzt um unser soft
scramble Pfanne mit Butter ist heiß
geworden das Ei hinein
zwei ab jetzt ihr kennt den schnacken
konstanter Bewegung halten das ganze mit
dir das perfekte weiche Rührei bekommen
das letzte was dann fehlt denn das hier
fertig ist ist nur noch anzurichten ich
freue mich selbst schon sehr darauf das
geht
[Musik]
was geht ab
Sauerteigbrot geröstet dann so ein ganz
weiches Rührei so ein sanftes Medium
Steak nicht wundern wir haben das an der
Schnittkante noch mal gebracht obendrauf
deine einzige Aufgabe ist heute zu essen
bisschen von dir zu erzählen und das
dann auch zu bewerten deshalb weil das
im Hinterkopf von 0 bis 10 Uhr du musst
später noch ein Urteil sprechen alles
klar jetzt ist nur die Frage Essen jetzt
mit Händen oder mit Besteck was sagst du
kaum gib ihm mit Hand Alter
das ist so deinen Standard Frühstück was
ist dein go-to was ist das was du immer
essen würdest
bisschen Scheiße
gefragt werden
Toast oder Brötchen Fitness
oder nicht
scheiß drauf gerade
aber ansonsten bin ich zum fitness-wahn
bin dann so Haferflocken
uns hier vor der Kamera zu versauen und
dann sehen wir uns zu Bewertung also ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich meine mein
Geschmack hast du voll getroffen ne ich
mag sehr gerne Rührei ich liebe Steak
und so ein Brot finde ich auch geil
tatsächlich habe ich noch nie gegessen
ich weiß es gar nicht auf was man da
noch besser machen kann Digger das ist
echt neun von zehn eigentlich zehn von
zehn aber
das ist genau mein Geschmack genau genau
Petersilie paar Gewürze Olivenöl zu sein
genau mein Geschmack getroffen
ich glaube wir werden heute viel Spaß
haben ich glaube auch ich gehe wieder
bzw chillen erstmal essen dann zum
Mittag da gibt's auch was besonderes ein
Klassiker komm ab hinterher
und wir kommen zum Mittagessen für das
ich schon einige Stunden früher starte
denn wir machen eine Bolognese wer liebt
keine Bolognese das habe ich mir auch
gedacht und habe deshalb für Kelvin eine
geplant dies in sich hat punchata
gemischtes Hack alles was eine richtige
Bolognese braucht wir haben es hier und
wir fangen direkt an indem wir unsere
kleinen geschnittene Pancetta das sind
so 200 g im Topf auslassen ein
Teststreifen von Jette da können wir
schon mal reingeben es zisch langsam
jetzt ist es Zeit für die restliche
Pancetta geben wir komplett hinein und
lassen jetzt wirklich so richtig schön
aus als wäre richtig viel Fett im Topf
stehen haben das nur von der Pancetta
kommt sonst kommt nichts dazu kein
Olivenöl
glaube ich muss niemandem erzählen dass
es gut riecht wenn man Pancetta aus
lässt das ist wahrscheinlich so Top 3
Küche
[Musik]
guckt Euch das einmal an goldbraune
Pancetta das war das Beste was man sehen
kann nimm eine Schöpfkelle holen unsere
Pancetta lassen ihr ein wenig abtropfen
und guckt mal wie viel Öl darin steht
guckt euch das an seht ihr das das
schwimmt der Boden steht in Öl bisschen
ausformen platt machen damit es
möglichst große Auflagefläche hat und
dann werden wir jetzt in zwei Etappen
unser gemischtes Hack anbraten zack
boah junge
let's go ich muss ihn so ein bisschen
helfen dass der alles bekommt
normalerweise macht man das dann so weil
so geht alles runter
drehen wir einmal und sagt vielleicht
boah
das ist Geschmack Schmack für unsere
Bolognese oh oh
wow so sieht das Ganze aus wenn es schön
durchgebraten ist bzw durchgebraten ist
falsche Wort in der Mitte ist es noch
relativ rosa wenn wir uns das mal so
anschauen aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
wenn das kocht ja noch lang genug aber
Röstaromen sind da das ist alles was
zählt das ist alles was wir wollen alles
was zählt alles was wir brauchen alles
was wir wollen und wir wollen es
natürlich nicht nur daran sondern auch
am anderen Hack mit dem ich genau das
gleiche mache also Leute sagt was ihr
wollt wenn das nicht richtig ist wenn
sich das nicht richtig anfühlt dann lügt
ihr und jetzt haben wir einen Satz den
wir zunächst einmal mit unserem Zwiebeln
lösen die garen jetzt da drin ein
bisschen da werdet ihr schon sehen die
kriegen richtig Farbe leider ein zweimal
drehen zack zack zack zack ich finde so
geil weil man weiß einfach schon so dass
das lecker wird das so krass irgendwie
weil dieser Schritt ist ja so mit der
wichtigste ja wenn du da keine keine
geilen Rüstung schaffst ja dann wird's
halt ne das ist die Tiefe die wir
brauchen bolognes ist auch eine Sache
die ich eigentlich nie in Restaurants
esse weil sie mich immer enttäuscht als
nächstes geben wir unsere Karotten dazu
ein bisschen an das riecht wirklich
super das waren übrigens zwei ganze
Möhren einfach halbiert und den
Scheibchen abgeschnitten vergessen
damit das hier danach kochen kann als
nächstes das sind so zwei Ästchen
Sellerie bisschen fein geschnitten
kommen auch dazu in der ganzen
ursprünglichen Form kommen weder Tomaten
noch Brühe dran sondern Milch deshalb
haben wir auch nicht viel Tomaten dran
jetzt gehen wir zwei fein gehackte
Knoblauchzehen dazu günstig noch mal mit
durch und heizen das ganze wie gesagt
noch mal ordentliche ein weil wir das
ganze jetzt tomatisieren zwei gute
Esslöffel Tomatenmark ordentlich durch
wenn alles durch das Tomatenmark in ein
rot getränkt ist löschen wir es mit
Weißwein ab
damit lösen sich jetzt auch so die
letzten Stoffe vom Topfboden und wir
können sicher gehen dass der gesamte
Geschmack in unsere Soße übergeht so
jetzt kommt die Hochzeit wir geben
einfach alles zusammen in den Topf was
wir noch haben fangen an mit einer Dose
Tomaten 500 Gramm gehackt
400 Milliliter Hühnerbrühe warum
Hühnerbrühe also wenn man jetzt nicht
selber Brühe macht dann sollte man eher
Hühnerbrühe kaufen weil in Rinderbrühe
viel weniger Kollagen Anteil und viel
weniger Fleischanteil drin ist als in
einer Hühnerbrühe ja und Collagen kriegt
natürlich dazu bei dass man so eine
dicke Soße bekommt so alles wieder
zurück durch nichts vom guten Saft hier
noch auf dem Tablet war verschwenden und
das sieht einfach auf Fische aus viel
mehr machen wir nicht abschmecken tun
wir am Ende einmal durchrühren und ihr
werdet merken das ist jetzt so stückig
das ganze aber in zwei drei Stunden das
eine wunderschöne Soße und so sieht das
ganze 3 Stunden später aus ihr seht
schon oben steht so ein Film aus Fett
das ist genau das wo wir wissen okay
hier haben wir richtig Geschmack drin
und es gibt noch einen kleinen Trick
zwar einfach so ein Kartoffelstampfer zu
benutzen bei sein Bolognese einfach eins
haben wir durchdrücken damit da wirklich
alles so schön mundgerecht klein ist
ansonsten Wasser steht schon für Nudeln
Nudeln sind ready probieren wir aber das
ist auch was taugt was wir gemacht haben
sehr gut also Nudeln kochen anrichten
los geht's
[Musik]
schon langsam dunkel hier Spaghetti
Bolognese das ist für mich auch so ein
richtiges Essen so im Winter Schaufeln
ja bestimmt riecht auf jeden Fall geil
wieder hier sehr gut die haben auch
einige Zeit gekocht drei vier Stunden
locker und haben das immer wichtig finde
ich dass man so einer Bolognese auch
Zeit gibt
ein bisschen den Formaten so mit dem
Essen habt ihr da auch persönliche Kopf
die Qualität vom Essen in den Formaten
also kommt immer auf das Format an so ne
du hast Formate muss halt selber kochen
es gibt Formate
korrekt so und es gibt halt Format so wo
du halt so ein bisschen hungern musst ne
ja ja und dann um die Nerven blank
liegen zu lassen so ne krass ja klar
also ich war aber beim promibus mal da
habt da gab es nur so boah was war das
Alter kennst du dieses Militär
vielleicht so oh Gott das ist doof
Linsensuppe ja und jeden Tag nur diese
diese Alter ja ja ein bisschen besser
das verstanden ich würde sagen wir
lassen uns das schmecken und sehen uns
gleich wieder der Teller ist wieder leer
das ist schon mal gut dass das
wichtigste jetzt muss es nur noch
geschmeckt haben was sagst du Kevin also
erstmal sehr sehr gut ja vielen lieben
Dank auf jeden Fall ne man schmeckt halt
dazu auch also das hat nicht einfach mal
so schnell nicht Spaghetti ist so
scheiße das hat auf jeden Fall auch
länger gedauert hat ne das Fleisch was
sehr geil ne und das hat auf jeden Fall
das ist keine Standard gewesen sowas da
ist genau kurz gesagt da ist Liebe drin
ich würde sagen pass auf hättest du ein
bisschen schärfer gewesen ich stehe auf
Schärfe okay wusstest du jetzt nicht
dann hättest Du von mir einen neuen
bekommen so wird es nach okay okay es
ist gut dann wenn geworden wäre nach dem
Frühstück am besten ja die Spannung raus
aber so werde ich probieren Sie mir beim
Abendessen zu holen ich habe mir was
überlegt was gesagt ist gerne
orientalisch sehr gerne und äh da habe
ich was für dich los geht's geil das
hier ist meine Vision hiermit möchte ich
es schaffen doch noch in Kelvins Herz zu
kommen guckt euch das an wir haben
wirklich alles was man sich tauschen
kann orientalisch wie gesagt
Lammkoteletts dazu gibt es ein
Bulgursalat in den all diese Zutaten
kommen und als Dip zu den Lammkoteletts
noch einen Joghurt minzgurktip ist das
geil ich finde leer machen wir als
allererstes einmal unseren Bulgursalat
fertig das hier ganz normaler Bulgur
einfach gequollen Bulgur Wasser 1:1
einfach Deckel drüber ziehen lassen
fertig genauso wie Couscous sehr sehr
einfach sehr sehr dankbar und unfassbar
lecker dazu kommen Frühlingszwiebel zack
dann 150 Gramm gehackte Tomaten die
genau hinschaut seht ihr da sind keine
Kerne mehr dabei wichtig dazu noch
gleiche Menge Paprika auch fein gehackt
eine rote Zwiebel auch fein gehabt und
ihr könnt euch vielleicht denken
Petersilie fein gehackt guckt euch das
mal an sieht doch wunderbar aus das
ganze braucht allerdings noch ein
Dressing und das machen wir als nächstes
dafür brauchen wir eine Schale Zitrone
Tomatenmark Cayennepfeffer und Honig so
wir nehmen zu allererst einmal die
Zitrone damit wir pressen zunächst
einmal den Saft aus der Zitrone zack das
sind jetzt vielleicht so bei Esslöffel
Zitronensaft dazu
Esslöffel Tomatenmark und ein wenig
Honig ist natürlich auch nicht fehlen
darf beim Dressing Olivenöl und dann
einfach dabei zuschauen wie das alles
wunderbar zu einem wird und eine
ordentliche Prise Salz jetzt übergießen
wir damit unseren Salat Bulgursalat
steht Gurke Minze als nächstes Gurke
rein und Minze
und Pfeffer
orange
Salz Knoblauch Granulat und Pfeffer das
ganze vermischen wir ein bisschen so
wenn wir das gemacht haben damit sie
noch ein bisschen besser anhafte in
unseren Koteletts nutzen wir ein
bisschen Worcester Sauce und geben die
einfach grob über unsere Koteletts
drüber los geht's
allen Seiten gleichmäßig oh junge
wirklich das ist crazy weil Lamm hat ja
auch so schon so einen starken Geschmack
und dann diese flavings daran hoffe das
haut unseren Kelvin vom Stuhl Plan
scheiß Olivenöl drauf und unsere
langkoteletts kommendes auch wow
jetzt heißt es warten bis die
Lammkoteletts golden braun sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier ist es also das Abendessen ihr seht
vielleicht hier so ein leichter Nebel in
der Luft und man riecht auch auf jeden
Fall das sowas wie gegrillt wurde wir
haben hier Lammkoteletts mit so einer
Kräuter Knoblauch Marinade wenn man
möchte dann ein Bulgursalat und Joghurt
Minze mit Gurke sieht total aus ja du
hast gesagt du hast Bock auf Fleisch so
du bist richtig gerne Fleisch dann ist
das glaube ich etwas was du magst weil
das schmeckt auch so intensiv also sieht
Hammer aus zu Anfang
oder bist du einfach nur nicht so der
Kopf sehr gerne und sehr gut sogar
beruflich einfach mal ja also was
brauchst an sich alles an Fleisch
natürlich ne aber was ich sehr gut
kannst du Spareribs Alter oha das dauert
sechs Stunden ungefähr
okay bis gleich dein Teller ist leer
meiner nicht ich kann einfach nicht mehr
essen aber du bist wirklich ein guter
Esser so viel kann man sagen und es
scheint dir geschmeckt sein ey brutal ja
also die letzte Nummer Abendessen noch
mal richtig ein rausgehauen Alter
hammergeil was hat dir gefallen also
Gefallen an dem Essen jetzt hier es ist
zum einen irgendwie so auch ein bisschen
Gesundheit ne also ich meine das ist
eigentlich ein Fitness food mäßig sowas
geile so Geschmack voll getroffen auf
jeden Fall Lammkotelett perfekt da gab
Punkt 1A mein Freund Alter das freut
mich sehr was heißt das was was gibt's
zu mir also wie gesagt auch mit dieser
Joghurts minssoße war das ne ähm
Bulgursalat plus die langkoteletts wie
gesagt perfekt jetzt hast du die Zähne
Alter
zehn auf jeden Fall super lecker
geschmeckt Alter vielen Dank es freut
mich sehr Kevin wirklich und ich arbeite
du bist wirklich ein sehr korrekter Typ
auch vor der Kamera muss ich erstmal
sagen es hat viel Spaß mit dir heute
danke dass du dabei warst aktuelle Frage
habe ich mir gerade noch gestellt
einfach super random zum Ende wer ist
die Person die dich so auf deine
Auftritte im TV angesprochen hat bei der
du es am wenigsten erwartet hättest
meinst du es vom Promis und so Promis
oder oder Italiener oder irgendwie sowas
irgendwie immer
verfolgt das boah da gab es einige
dicker das geht von von Rappern bis hin
zu keinem Mario Basler oder so weißt du
ja ja das ist ein bisschen zu Youtubern
dicker das ist eigentlich äh da gibt's
so viele Menschen Digger die die ganzen
öffentlichen Personen die das sind die
nicht gefährdet haben
das natürlich
ein bisschen raten vielleicht auch in
den Kommentaren weil wir sind die
Gerüchteküche anschweißen danke dass du
dabei warst hier ist ein für euch
vorgeschlagenes Video darunter könnt ihr
den Kanal abonnieren so wie Kevin das
auch schon so schön gesagt hat Freund
aktivieren auch ne ja bis zum nächsten
Mal ciao